[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti è bello iniziare un
Talk con il canto Il frinire dei grilli
anche un po' per stemperare la tensione
Insomma di iniziare questo
Ma quali suoni in realtà hanno la
capacità di evocare tante belle
sensazioni come quelle della natura del
relax della vacanza no come il frinire
dei grilli Certamente
ci aiuta perché ci riporta un po' in
paesaggi bucolici Ma a chi di noi il
frinire dei grilli suscita o evoca una
sensazione legata in qualche modo al
gusto di un buon cibo perché quanti
hanno assaggiato un grillo
quanti mangiano insetti in questa platea
alzate la mano qualcuno l'ha mai
assaggiati
beh ce n'è ce n'è qualcuno Eppure
secondo alcune Stime Adesso non vorrei
sorprendervi ma
si dice che noi occidentali in media
Quindi anche noi seduti in questa platea
consumiamo circa mezzo chilo di insetti
all'anno Mi direte com'è possibile è
possibile perché gli insetti sono
bibitari sono praticamente ovunque Anzi
Qualcuno dice che il nostro pianeta più
che essere il pianeta degli esseri umani
e il pianeta degli insetti perché se
andassimo a misurare il loro peso e lo
comparassimo con il peso degli uomini
belli insetti pesano molto di più di noi
ma quando quindi noi andiamo a
raccogliere e processare materia prima
di origine vegetale che poi diventa
fondamentalmente gli alimenti che tutti
mangiamo come pasta e passata di
pomodoro piuttosto che cioccolata caffè
succhi di frutta Beh in qualche modo gli
insetti che comunque finiscono in queste
produzioni alimentari e quindi noi
poiché non li possiamo tirare via li
andiamo a trovare nei nostri alimenti
però voi Mi direte d'accordo il nostro
consumo di mezzo chilo di insetti
all'anno e pur sempre con inconsapevole
E perché dovremmo passare da un consumo
inconsapevole ad un consumo consapevole
di insetti commestibili oggi cercherò di
darvi almeno tre buoni motivi Quantomeno
per guardare da un punto di vista
diverso
all'entomofobia e allora parto da una
parola una parola molto di moda che la
sostenibilità perché gli insetti
commestibili sono tra gli alimenti più
sostenibili che noi abbiamo in natura
perché
il concetto della sostenibilità è
complesso non lo possiamo trattare tutti
e tutto in questi pochi minuti
dovremmo parlare di economia circolare
dovremo parlare di stagionalità dovremmo
parlare di biodiversità oppure di costi
necessari per produrre e trasformare un
determinato alimento o di produrlo in
una determinata parte del mondo e poi
trasportarlo per il suo consumo da
tutt'altra parte Insomma sarebbero tante
le voci da tenere in considerazione ma
proviamo a fare solo alcuni calcoli se
noi fossimo degli allevatori degli
allevatori di mucche per esempio
sapremmo che per produrre un chilogrammo
della carne che noi mangiamo dovremmo
utilizzare tra gli 8 e 10 kg di mangime
per avere quindi un chilo di carne di
mucca più andiamo a ridurre la pezzatura
dell'animale più questo coefficiente di
conversione
migliora migliora il punto tale che se
parlassimo di grilli per esempio con lo
stesso mangime 10 kg di mangime noi
potremmo ottenere 5 kg di carne e allora
se consideriamo Quanto costa in termini
di acqua o di terreno abile la
produzione di quel mangime sulla
disponibilità forse riusciamo a fare
qualche calcolo che va a favore dei
grilli commestibili
ma non è finita vedete dietro di me o
dietro di voi una bella immagine di
meravigliosa sostanza organica lo scarto
degli animali da reddito ora oltre allo
scarto che nella produzione industriale
sia perché pensate che insomma gli
animali grandi hanno anche il pelo
piuttosto che le ossa tutto quello che
non viene normalmente mangiato invece
negli insetti commestibili quasi tutto
finisce come parte edibile abbiamo anche
gli scarti le cosiddette deiezioni anche
quelle degli animali grandi ovviamente
lo conosciamo ne conosciamo anche un po'
la caratterizzazione olfattiva no quando
lo spargiamo sul terreno perché è un
ottimo concime per il terreno per la
salute del sole delle piante e lo è
anche quello degli insetti e dei grilli
in particolare chiamato fras ma oltre a
questo c'è un altro elemento importante
che ha a che fare con il cambiamento
climatico e con i gas serra Durante
l'intero ciclo di vita degli insetti
commestibili e dei grilli i gas serra
prodotti sono assolutamente inferiori
rispetto ai gas prodotti dagli animali
più grandi e dai ruminanti In
particolare ma anche le loro deiezioni
producono molta meno ammoniaca che
quando va a finire nell'atmosfera in
quanto CO2 equivalente interviene in
maniera molto più positiva su quello che
è il cosiddetto effetto serra sul
cambiamento climatico Quindi abbiamo
detto sono sostenibili ma il loro gusto
in pochi no gli hanno assaggiati 2
miliardi di persone al mondo già oggi li
consumano e li ritengono buoni gustosi
una prelibatezza però finché non li
assaggiamo non possiamo dire no che lo
siano Ma questo non ci sorprende Da che
mondo è mondo andare incontro ad
alimenti nuovi che non fanno parte delle
nostre stesse condizioni della nostra
diciamo consapevolezza in termini di
gusto è chiaramente ci lascia un po'
perplessi No era così anche per
L'Aragosta sapete quando e con
Conquistadores sbarcarono nel sud e
America e si trovarono di fronte a
questo strano animale marino che diciamo
non era neanche bellissimo No da vedere
lo utilizzavano come cibo per gli
schiavi e per i prigionieri di guerra
oggi è una delle prelibatezze più
ricercate al mondo e più o meno lo
stesso percorso l'ha fatto di sushi
negli ultimi 20 anni quindi sul gusto
abbiamo bisogno di andare un po' oltre
di rompere quella tensione verso
l'ignoto e provare imparare a cucinare
a rigettarli e farli diventare un po'
parte della nostra tradizione Dunque
sono sostenibili probabilmente sono più
buoni e da un punto di vista
nutrizionale la loro sicurezza ce la
raccontata con delle opinioni
scientifiche anche molto recenti la
lessa la full standard agency Europea
quindi sono sicuri per il consumo umano
e sono anche nutrizionalmente molto
validi solo un po' di esempi se noi
avessimo 100 grammi di polvere di Grillo
in un sacchetto oltre la metà di questi
100 grammi sarebbero proteine pure
proteine di origine animale
quindi completa dei Nove aminoacidi
essenziali cosiddetti perché noi non li
possiamo sintetizzare li Dobbiamo
assumere tramite la dieta e tutto il
resto Grassi prevalentemente insaturi
tante vitamine soprattutto del gruppo B
poi calcio Ferro magnesio potassio da un
punto di vista nutrizionale quindi un
altro punto per i nostri piccoli amici
nel momento in cui abbiamo ottenuto la
nostra polvere di Grillo che ne possiamo
fare come la possiamo inserire nelle
nostre abitudini alimentari perché per
noi occidentali andare a mangiare un
insetto così dal quale non è abbiamo
detto così scontato così semplice ma se
fosse una farina un nuovo ingrediente un
novel Food da inserire in altri alimenti
che sono invece parte delle nostre
abitudini Beh Allora potremmo realizzare
veramente tanti tanti nuovi alimenti e
perché si possono realizzare prodotti di
base dolce o di base salata apportando
Però quella sostenibilità quel gusto e
quelle proprietà nutrizionali di cui
abbiamo parlato prima
ora forse L'errore più grande che noi
potremmo fare è quello di pensare che
gli insetti commestibili i grilli
edibili in particolare possono essere
una minaccia alle nostre tradizioni
quando invece dovremmo vederli Forse da
un'altra prospettiva Sì sono il cibo del
futuro ma perché perché possono dare
Certamente un'opportunità alla nostra
economia una nuova risorsa anche a
disposizione degli agricoltori che
potrebbero in nuovi allevamenti
differenziare la loro produzione
potrebbero essere una nuova risorsa
nelle mani dell'Industria agroalimentare
perché potrebbe ampliare il proprio
prodotto e il proprio portafoglio di
prodotti e infine Quindi per noi
consumatori perché Potremmo avere a
fianco ai nostri alimenti tradizionali
nuovi alimenti non del Food con delle
caratteristiche
migliorative da un punto di vista
nutrizionale e di sostenibilità
quindi
sperando di avervi dato qualche
indicazione in più e avere arricchito un
po' il pensiero con qualche punto di
vista nuovo per poter guardare a questi
nuovi ingredienti a questi nuovi piccoli
animali da inserire nella nostra
alimentazione io non posso che augurarvi
buon appetito
[Applauso]